so again also from my side thanks to the
organizers for inviting you here and
welcome to you all and it's a pleasure
to speak directly after Alex I can
assure you the environment at Duke is in
fact fantastic even though there are
also other places which I think are very
good so we're sampling a bit of a bigger
space recently okay so in this
particular workshop you hear a lot as
just now for instance about positioning
of nucleosomes right and what our
preferences for DNA binding proteins
that might come up in the next talk a
hunch and then sort of all of this
massive machinery works together and at
the end there's like a tiny little thing
happening at the end it's not that
important actually right just this
little arrow here and so what I thought
I focus on is the reverse of this view
were essentially transcriptions like
this little an important thing upstream
that happens occasionally but what
really determines the cellular fate and
the states in the cell is actually what
happens to the transcripts so how does a
particular ginga transcribed how does it
get processed how is it exported how
stable is it how efficient is the
translation initiation what's the rate
of translation where is it localized to
which cell a compartment and so forth
these are all things that happen post
inscription Lee and of course now we
have technology to sa essentially
interactions of regulatory factors on
RNA as we do in DNA and also what's
really exciting to profile not just
steady state RNA but actually these
different states so what is the nascent
RNA what is the nuclear versus
cytoplasmic fraction what's the
stability and a half-life of RNA and so
forth and so for all of these we have
assays available by now and so I thought
I focus on two topics that we've been
working on in my group for a while now
there are a bit complimentary so that
allows you to see the parallels that we
actually have between the
transcriptional in the post
inscriptional world so I'll give a
little bit of an introduction overview
of how you actually sa regulatory
interactions on the RNA side and then
also what cut type of exciting things we
might be able to tell from these
different our nasik essays when you move
beyond steady-state RNA so these are
essentially the two half
my talk today and I think we'll see some
interesting parallels especially also
what algorithms we might have to design
of these purposes because both of these
as it turns out use location specific
information so it's going to be
interesting to see if some of these fast
algorithms for expression quantification
for instance that we heard about
yesterday still work here because we are
actually interested in reference
locations as you'll see okay so why
would we bother with RNA binding
proteins well there might not be quite
as many as transcription factors but
it's not too far off these numbers keep
rising in fact there's many unusual
enzymes that people have seen recently
being associated to RNA as well they
come in a whole bunch of different
classes there's lots of RNA binding
domains that field is much less explored
and understood than the domains for
transcription factors we don't quite
understand yet what all these things are
doing because they might impact the very
different levels they might impact
translation but maybe if they're also
present in the nucleus they do something
else there so we often see that RNA
binding proteins have different roles
lots of them are supposed to do some
moonlighting in different places in the
cell and often they also contain one and
more by no more than one binding domain
so that you could actually really
interact with different target sets and
sites and sequences at different times
or different states in the cell and so
my group has been working sort of in
parallel we do still continue and it's
about half half in the lab you can ask
my students Mahmoud and Henrietta are
there they work on this side of the lab
where we actually deal with
transcriptional control and how to
enhance us find their target genes and
how does chromatin change over time
course data all these exciting things
and then in parallel we have these
essays now that can look at the
transcriptome so we can do occupancy
profiling that tells us where something
is stuck to our neighbors not what it is
and we can also zoom in then with ever
increasing resolution to identify
individual target sites for specific
proteins the resolution here is actually
really comparable to probably chip xox
if Nexus on the transcriptional site and
you'll see why that is so how do people
start to I
identify targets for these RNA binding
proteins was actually similar to chip so
you do an RNA immunoprecipitation
instead of chromatin and initially this
was done by hybridizing the target
sequences that you pull out and your IP
two arrays and to identify the target
genes but not necessarily the locations
where they bond and then from but their
nails lab one sequencing came along you
could start to do RNA crosslinking and
IP and then followed by sequencing to
get higher resolution so what you use is
essentially UV light to crosslink you
don't use a chemical you can cross link
on RNA with UV light you can then
essentially extract fragments where a
particular protein was bound attach your
linkers and sequence and amplify as you
would do for chip and you can already
see indicated here often through this
cross-linking something actually happens
at the target site we call this
diagnostic events and that helps us to
narrow down where exactly in the genome
in transcriptome these factors might
actually interact in a specific protocol
that induces a lot of these diagnostic
events is called Park clip which is a
modification where your cross link
actually with a different wavelength and
you also add you pulse fourth iou into
the cells and what happens is that
fourth I you is really amenable to being
cross-linked at at this particular
wavelength and so you get a higher and
Richmond the higher signal to noise
compared to regular clip you see a
better local enrichment of your reads
here but what also happens is that the
fourth iou is actually misread when you
do your reverse strand synthesis and
library construction so what you happens
is that at locations preferentially at
locations where really a factor
interacted with the RNA which you t to
see convergence in the actual sequences
so this is what we utilize by now five
years ago when we develop the first pika
finder for this Park live data and you
can see sort of what happens here in
this particular example you have your
regular we depth from the sclip library
here in gray and now what we can do is
we can actually
for an excess a local excess of these
t2c mutations in your sequence
traditionally guide us where the
interaction happens other than just
recover it from the library and so this
gives us this much higher resolution you
can see here right you have these gray
read clusters here and they kind of also
flow together because as it happens you
have to target sites for palm to here in
this particular target sequence that are
pretty close to each other but these
diagnostic mutations so the signal in
this case is the relative fraction of T
to see conversions smoothed over a local
window so you have a part in smoother
here can you see that the ste to see
conversion exceeds essentially the
background which is the relative T
density in the sequence without
mutations just how rich is your T so
what's the prior in a way to have any
kind of event to being seen at this
location and you can see here that you
with very high accuracy with almost new
single nucleotide resolution for some
proteins it depends on how well they
crossing you're able to actually
identify the target sites now so this
paralyzer approach turned out to be
pretty useful because what it does is
implicitly actually cancel out any kind
of library bias or sequencing depth the
different expression levels because we
only look for this T to see excess
mutation relative to the T density and
the reach that have teased in them at
that location so I don't need to
explicitly actually model for instance
the variability of RNA see coverage of
something here cpg island and when you
don't have enough teeth well as it so
happens cpg islands are not so much in
RNA right so they are more in the genome
actually the luckily for us especially
the untranslated regions where many of
these proteins like to bind our au rich
so there is of course this potential
problem and this is why people have
developed and as we'll see this is
something that we deal with now a
different clip protocol so you can still
do regular hits clip as it's called now
clip seek where you don't induce this
type of mutation where I don't need to
pulse with forth I you and you're not
dependent on the t you can use modified
running as well but the crow
slinking isn't quite as good for that
their ways around it essentially at
least in terms of protocols and using
different protocols so just to wrap up
what we can do with this type of
approach in this first part is that of
course isn't a large interest also now
in more Princeton's and congenital
disorders to understand how our and a
regulation plays a role there in one
particular study that we were involved
here as was a collaboration with tom to
show was to figure out what the fmr1
protein so the federal acts mental
retardation related gene actually binds
to and while its targets are and what
the specificities are and this end we
had essentially so fragile x syndrome is
usually caught caused by a triplet
expansion in the promoter so this is not
what we're looking at here of course you
can get the syndrome also by mutations
in the binding domains and so we
essentially profiled the wild-type fmr1
gene it has different isoforms so we
need to profile the different isoforms
as well as the variant with the patient
mutation and see what happens and so in
this case if fmr1 gene actually has as
you can see three binding domains of two
different motif classes to actually
interact and find target sites and so
what we noticed essentially is after we
identified sites here that you had two
different classes of sites with two
different types of sequence motifs that
are again here at the locations where
the t2c conversion exceeds the
background again with very high
resolution and essentially that allowed
us to do motif finding when we did motif
finding essentially found two different
sequence motifs that were present and
now we could actually compare the
patient mutation which happens in this
KH domain here to the wild-type and see
which type of motifs do we
preferentially lose and in this way even
be able to not just find the target
motifs but also assign the motifs to the
particular domain that was actually
binding to this particular sequence
preference so what you see is if
actually look then at the mutation
versus the wild type where it likes to
bind you see that in this AC UK target
motif you have a much bigger decrease
essentially in binding than for target
sites that contain this other motif now
and so from there on we could then of
course find pathways and see what the
target genes are enriched and so forth
but this is the type of resolution and
data that you actually get out on the
RNA side so I think it's a pretty
exciting venue to be in so yeah so we
didn't look at this so all of this this
is a different question that will get to
here now of course RNA binding proteins
a lot of them have primary sequence
preferences but these primary sequence
preferences if nothing else will occur
in a secondary structure context the RNA
can fold up and we might actually have
additional information from the
secondary structure around the primary
sequence preferences does the sequence
occur in the loop in a bulge in an
unstructured region and so forth the
problem is that is of course very little
ground truth to it so what we recently
switched to is to start simulating
libraries to be able to see how well we
could actually identify clusters and
then in those simulated libraries we
could embed motifs or different
secondary structural features to see how
much that actually helps us secondary
structure prediction is really
notoriously difficult right we are
talking about the whole transcript we
can't fold the whole transcript to the
minimum free energy and think that this
makes any sense even looking at
posterior probabilities of just being
paired and unpaired even that signal
vanishes once you go to 200 nucleotides
or so so you really can only look at the
very small local context with purely
prediction methods so far so what we've
done this was published at PSB just now
is to simulate essentially starting from
something like the flux simulator to get
fragments and transcript abundances at
first and then fragments from these
transcripts we can now essentially say
or what within our particular
rna-binding protein a known one or a one
that we make up actually like to bind to
then essentially figure out what
the library construction which fragments
would it leave how would it amplify what
amplification biases would we get what
other reads what of that what type of
diagnostic events would we be able to
put in there and then actually have at
least simulated benchmark data that
allows us also to evaluate different
clip protocols so Park live and uses
these t2c conversions regular hits clip
has more of a deletion of single
nucleotides there's a protocol called I
clip that truncates when it hits the
essentially where the protein is vining
so digests down really the fragments to
exactly where the protein bound and so
all of these different things we can
actually include in our prediction right
we don't need to not just do these t2c
conversions so we switched to different
models now where we essentially replace
this previous approach this paralyzer
completely with the hierarchical
probabilistic model the closest that's
been done in this direction is actually
where Nico so if you have questions
about models like this you can also ask
him and the basic idea here now is that
we have about a multinomial distribution
of these diagnostic events and that
these diagnostic events are correlated
if we are actually at a true binding
site if we have replicates so
essentially we're moving now to the
scheme of the type of data that for
instance encode produces where you have
multiple replicates where you have a
control input type a background
sequenced library and so forth so these
were all things that five years ago we
just didn't have available and so
there's paralyzed a very simple
heuristic of looking for an excess of T
to see conversions went a long way but
now we actually have different type of
data that we need to consider and that
allows us to really use a different
strategy to identify these sites so
that's work in progress we can
essentially now have our article model
where we start with the duration a
multinomial and then the actual reads of
different types of diagnostic events if
you have good replicates you can even
learn what type of diagnostic events are
present from the data from scratch you
can account them for or you need to
account in fact in this case now of
course for RNA sequencing depth and
expression level for the gene that we
had previously implicit in our approach
and we need to link these individual
sites in whether there are mutations at
a specific site in a larger context
because these sites occur not just one
at one time but they coker clustered in
the genome and of course you also want
to extend your cluster call to the size
of the read length for the very least
write these mutations are somewhere in
the read if you just call individual
locations where you find them you don't
find the whole binding site and so you
need to come up with post-processing
tricks and so forth and so here we
decided we put that straight into the
model where we have coverage of the
sequence reads these diagnostic
mutations and a local dependency
structure and hidden Markov model
actually glued together and so I can't
show you real results there yet we are
starting to do better it was actually
took us a long time to be their own all
tool which has come a long way but
especially with this type of simulated
libraries we can now actually find out
okay where is actually improvement
really coming from wood replicates
really help wouldn't need a sequence
deeper and so forth we can actually
simulate that and get ideas also how to
design experiments okay so that was the
first part I saw there were some hands
in between I think out of the corner of
my eyes yeah experiment and I wonder how
matches kind of evolution conservation
of this motif in D so you can also of
course use I mean you can use additional
features for instance so then do motif
prediction or something based on these
side calls and it is usually as you
could see in this one example for fmri
one they have a for nucleotide sequence
motif it's really very short so the
local context will definitely play a
role and so if you do motif finding
people have started looking into this
you can use conservation or secondary
structure features and so forth to
actually then try to figure out what are
actually the preferences in the first
place that guide the proteins to that
place
finally motif in the in the in the
experimental data use it kind of similar
regions another organism then see
whether you can just look at the
conservation that wouldn't really help
you there's an overall conservation bias
towards the beginning and end of the UT
are for instance likely because that is
where enzymes you know hey for for
cleavage and polyadenylation for
instance vine and so forth so it's it's
really tricky to do this just by
conservation actually and there's what
we think there's a lot of turnover of
these sites we typically see that you
have actually some jeans even have 20 or
30 target peaks in them and so this is
actually the next step now where we are
to try to understand are each of these
sites individually important or do you
just want to make sure to reach a
certain level of attracting proteins to
bind there but each individual site like
in a transcription factor and in a
cluster of transcription factor binding
sites that each site might not be
important these are just questions we
can now start to address I would like to
go on actually so that I get to my
second part I'm sorry guys a very quick
question oh oh that's so they all start
so what's the binding then predict you
so let's say you know everywhere where
your RNA by what about well that's the
perfect segue in fact to my second part
yay no of course we what you need to
complement this binding information is
to look at for instance knockdown data
like we did for fmr1 where you had point
mutations or knock downs of the factors
and then actually see what happens now
in the cell right and so does this
particular protein is it important for
processing of the transcript or
stability or translation and so forth
and so for translation in particular
there's been a really cool essay that I
think everybody should really become
more aware of because it has I think I
potential to definitely complement if
not replace regular RNA seek for many
applications
I think you should probably be aware of
that and also think about there is no
single cell data on this just yet but
hopefully at some point there will be so
maybe than other people here will get
even more excited so the essay that
immunised co-drivers on profiling or
ribose seek it was actually developed by
nick and goalie on jonathan Wiseman's
lab they're here at Berkeley and UCSF
and ideas the following that we might
get a snapshot of what actually gets
translated and determine what
transcripts might make it into proteins
from sequencing so not by mass spec so
effectively you again stall in this case
with cycloheximide typically ribosomes
on the RNA he digests the overhanging
fragments so that you have hopefully
mono mono somes mono ribosomes not
nucleosomes ray and then actually
sequence what was bound and protected
essentially by these ribosomes with the
idea of something is actively
translating you of course get many reads
from these libraries when you try to
purify the ribosome bone fragments and
so this could have very high a player
resolution because these sequence reads
can map anywhere along a transcript and
you can affect sort of see what happens
here a little bit if this is the start
codon and here is a stop codon you see
that these reads start positions then
are offset from the actual code on that
gets translated because the ribosome
covers a larger fragment and so if i
look at annotated coding genes as a
benchmark and topeka i can typically
figure out the offset and actually
really see which codon actually this
particular ribosome was translating at
that position yeah and so people started
to try to use this data ever of course
since the protocol was published about
seven years ago and the first set of
metrics were just essentially just
looked at the global characteristics of
these of these libraries so for instance
is there an enrichment over RNA seek
right so excess relative enrichment for
specific transcripts compared to others
will tell you their translated highly
the next thing was a ribosome release
score by a bit more precisely look at
enrichments of or depletion of three
prime UTR over CD s reads right because
as you leave the coding sequence there
shouldn't be any scanning ribosomes
anymore of course the ribosome will scan
so you see some reads up here but you
shouldn't really see any reads after you
if encountered the stop codon so you can
use that as a metric and then people
started as we'll see to become a bit
more specific for this protocol and
actually saying well maybe we can see in
frame reads actually write the ribosome
moves three nucleotides at a time so we
should be able to find an excess for
instance with a kind of chi-square test
statistic for having an excessive reads
in one frame over the two other frames
and that should give us a much better
indication if ribosomes were really
moving in steps of 3 through the
sequence and in particular just two
years ago a year and a half ago actually
there were two papers that now figure it
out that if you get your library
conditions just right and you look at
specific fragment length in this case
typically it's 29 nucleotides for for
animal genomes you see this really the
really striking bias so this is a meta
plot again upstream of the start codon
you really see that you get this 3 prime
periodicity is a very strong signal in
your data not 10.3 nucleotides this time
it's 3 and you can see that this is not
quite as pronounced if you use slightly
different read lengths because the
nucleus of the ribosome covers exactly
29 nucleotides if it is engaged fully
assembled 80's and was active and
scanning or try actively translating
actually
the reed leg is just what no no no I
mean you digest away all the overhanging
fragments and you try to you try to
purify the exact footprint of the
ribosome right and so in our library
that wheel in sequence and said well we
need to see the data wasn't published at
the time when we heard about these
studies let's just do this ourselves and
actually see what we get and you sort of
see about seventy or eighty percent of
enrichment for the actual frame that's
used in about ten percent of background
for each of the other two frames this
again starts on stop codon aligned so
that led us to think about well maybe
you can do better than just a simple
chi-square test for read for a frame
preference because you might just by
chance by amplification buyers and other
things get an excessive reads in just
one frame without seeing a consistent
three periodic signal throughout your
whole coding sequence so how can we look
at that well Fourier transform came to
mind and you can see what happens here
if you take a fairly a really good
example case 300 nucleotide exon hey we
have in this case even ninety percent of
frame bias and you see that if you do a
discrete Fourier transform you get a
peek at points33 at a one-third Hertz
frequency now so if you now go to a
presumably non-coding region with less
coverage so there's a link RNA exon here
you might still see a frame bias and the
chi-square test will tell you oh you cou
preferential through periodic bias here
let's call this coding but if you
actually look at the the spectrogram
there is no point 33 periodicity here
now so this statistic can really be
fooled just by you know a few positions
where you have just by chance more reach
than in other positions and they just so
happen to be modular three in distance
from each other the problem is that the
typically the Fourier transform will
still get you the regular or
run-of-the-mill Fourier transform will
be too noisy because of course you have
few reads in many cases and you want to
have a stable estimator for your
frequencies and it so turns out that
this will
actually perfectly developed they are
theoretically optimal filter banks that
allow you to minimize the bias and the
variance of your estimators of the
spectrogram so this has been developed
in the 80s by Thompson there's a really
nice review for if you're interested in
this from just a couple of years ago and
they essentially the the theory tells
you that there is a filter bank that you
can run your original sequence through
and then average the spectrograms that
you get on the other end to actually
amplify or get an unbiased estimator as
well as you can under certain of course
noise assumptions and so forth what that
doesn't practice you see here we here we
have that same coding exon and here you
actually now see what this amplified
cleaned up multi tapered as it's called
spectrogram looks like you have really a
much much better cleaner signal-to-noise
picture here than in the original
Fourier transform now and you can do
statistical tests on this and actually
say okay with what particular is a you
know cut off of a point of five p-value
was there a significant three periodic
frequency detected in my signal and I
don't have I don't need to correct for
multiple hypotheses here because I'm
just testing for this particular
frequency right yeah no don't you just
know the reading frame from sequence
could we know genetic code I mean why
why do you need to know do something a
bit lost Eric always ask the questions
before your slides come you're thinking
that it was supposed to be asleep right
why are you awake here come on we'll get
there I think you'll see why what we can
actually do with this now okay
what is for you to have something look
okay okay let's just look at this we
effectively thought okay let's just try
this in our library this is actually
pretty low coverage you had to think
about 15 million of these 29 nucleotide
long reads left in the end because you
throw away a lot of your actual
sequences and so here you see how many
from all exons in the genome annotated
exons if we've been them by length or by
just three expression Turtles how much
do we actually call that you would see
as RNA seek being minimally expressed so
you have some RNA seek evidence a few
reads that the scene might be expressed
how many of the actions for different
lengths and coverage or expression do we
get and you can see that even at low
expression rates and really short like
sequences you would be able to call
quite a lot and once you go to medium
expression levels or reasonably normal
excellent size length you're actually
getting them a signal for the majority
of the exons so it's on a single axon
level of course now Eugene will have
multiple exon so your signal is actually
typically stronger than that but to come
to erics question there's been a lot of
debate in the literature about micro
peptides so essentially whether the
genome in fact might encodes so for some
conspiracy theorists thousands of micro
peptides that evaded our annotation so
far because they're too short because
annotating from the from the sequence
bias works in a single genome if you
have a few hundred nucleotide it works
with conservation if you have 100
nucleotides but typically around a
hundred amino acids actually is the
cutoff where people annotated proteins
in the genome annotation pipelines so
anything smaller than hundred amino
acids is called a micro peptide and now
we even have a dwarf so dwarf orff's
that are like 20 nucleotides long or
something like that and so we wanted to
see can we push it would be be able in
vivo now see whether such small orff's
that are present everywhere in the
genome are they actually used and it's
also interesting in the context of link
rnase because people
use these early rival seek libraries to
essentially come to the exact opposite
conclusions their papers that say oh
there's it's clear evidence that linked
rnas are not translated and there are
other papers that came bout back to back
on the same data and say hey they're all
translated there are no non-coding genes
everything gets translated right and so
we thought made this approach you might
have a road in to actually see whether
that works let me just show you here a
few examples again a bit more unbiased
not best case worst case but here we
have 3x on / genes that are exactly of
the same length and they have the same
number of reads lining to them and so
here you can see that you have a coding
exon here you have something in the five
prime utr here's something in the link
RNA and again here are these multi
tapered periodogram and you see again
that the coding sequence is the only one
that gives you this clear peak okay you
can also see that we can tell likely
alternative start codons apart from each
other at least if they are reasonably
spaced from each other so that's for
instance one thing that again we can't
just do from the sequence but we can in
vivo see which ones are actually
translated by looking at you no
alternative by walking back from a stop
codon and walking back to different atg
candidates and seeing what the coverage
and the periodicity is and so of course
here this is pretty short so you just
about get a significant peak here you go
to the next one on all your peak is very
clear at the one-third frequency if you
extend further there's very little
coverage there it's not really framed
preferential and you see that actually
the the signal also drops again so with
a few simple heuristics we can actually
extend and determine the particular
start codon that's used and so here's
now where we detect translation unbiased
and every annotated thing in the genome
be its anti-sense process transcript or
whatever encode uses as categories and
so we find in this particular cell type
11,500 coding genes as being translated
we also find other fragments so we find
of course upstream open reading frames
now as well so in our case these are
separate frames that are separated from
the main coding sequence and are in the
five prime utr and
so this has been a proposed regulatory
mechanism that should impact on the
translation of the actual coding
sequence but again of course half of the
transcripts have a potential URF in them
that you know is start and stop codon in
frame isn't too hard to get but we can
tell now which hundreds of genes might
actually make use of this regulatory
mechanism and we can also look at more
exotic parts in the genome and for
instance yes find periodic spectra in
for instance link RNAs few dozen genes
or in pseudo genes that are actually
translated and the evidence comes from
uniquely aligning reads just to the
pseudogene not to the original gene so
this is also an interesting observation
you might still have translation of
these pseudogenes let me just go briefly
towards the end here so we then wanted
to see is there any real evidence that
even these you know 80 link RNA so these
hundred crosses transcripts might
actually really encode for something so
we look at conservation you can see what
that typically looks like for protein
coding gene along the start and stop
codon you see again three prime
periodicity for the you are so instance
interestingly you see a conservation at
the start codon and the stop codon but
not of the actual sequence you know
underlining yes there's some functional
something functional conserved here that
might distract the ribosomes from the
real coding sequence but itself it's
likely not producing a peptide because
there's no selection on the amino acid
itself and then again on the link RNAs
this is almost flat so even the ones
that we detect we see just a little bit
of hump again at the at the start codon
but there's no three periodicity anymore
in the conservation and the sequence and
so here now for pseudogenes you see that
that conservation is getting eroded to
write because these are decaying genes
ok and the last thing that I want to
point out we can now go to mass spec
data also and see could this actually
replace mass spec altogether so coming
to this idea that I mentioned that this
essay might actually really complement
as a routine thing regular RNA seek
because in this essay you find what's
actually coding and
so we essentially designed a mass spec
library equerry library just from the
coding sequences that we annotated from
our one data set and then compared it
against all of uniprot to look in deep
mass spec data for that same cell type
and you can see that we pretty much
identify exactly the same things that
identified by uniprot there's a few
things that we find extra and that have
reasonable expression levels the things
that are called by uniprot extra are so
low and they are an asic steady state
level that these might even be false
calls to begin with right you have
always a false discovery rate associated
with these calls so we can identify
spect essentially the translated
proteins as well as if i had uniprot and
the deep mass spec data set just from
this one library right then we could
also see now what do we find can we
confirm some of these new peptides and
here again yeah we do find three
peptides into unique link rnas but
nothing of the 79 or something that had
this periodic reads in them and that
again now is of course then the question
of what do these things actually do is
there a function for for instance these
linked RNA or so that we detected or
maybe more related to you or if so that
protects somehow the rnase from
degradation but not might actually have
any role in producing of stable peptide
because we don't detect them in mass
spec okay so with that I would like to
finish up and thank the people in the
lab who did that work so the first part
is essentially an rna-binding proteins
as a postdoc in the lab for a few years
Neil mukerji and the second part
essentially is done philip davis are
developing that new p kohler algorithm
and then antheia and lorenzo that the
experimental and the computational work
on this ribose seek analysis on the
rival taper i was published last month
so you can read all about it elsewhere
thank you
couple of questions
yeah so I have a question on the second
pipe so in European how much
quantitative is this very first fighting
like can you do like alternative
translation like we do it and our
differential is especially so the rag oh
yeah so the regular mass spec data gives
you these I back values that are
somewhat proportional to the protein
abundance and our fourier coefficient is
slightly better in the correlation then
the regular RNA seek coverage would be
and of course it looks at something
quite different it's of course dependent
a bit on the coverage how strong your
signal is but it really looks at this
periodicity so we're developing
essentially now pretty simple in your
model to combine the regular RNA seek
evidence and the superiority evidence to
see how far we can actually get in
predicting translation rates and for
that of course the real data to use this
psiloc like pulse labeling essentially
of proteomics data that also tells you
about the translation rates because the
corresponding thing to these ribosome
comfort fragments would really be the
translation rate and not the overall
abundance because we don't know about
the stability of the proteins yeah so KH
domains they usually come in a motor
domain fashion can you relate
distinguish which of the foot pain
without the witch of the
sounded fine yes so we haven't tried to
really resolve it to that point so you
could see like anecdotally in this plot
that i showed you could even see that
there were two peaks very close to each
other that might essentially pair with
these two KH domains but the data is
still very noisy there's a lot of things
that's what I meant that's why we're
developing this new approach now as well
is essentially a lot of Peaks that are
shared between the different RNA binding
proteins now that we have libraries many
libraries for different proteins there's
a strong sequence bias of the enzyme
that digests essentially the fragments
that go into your library sequencing so
that could create spurious Peaks just
based on that and also it's likely that
you simps have something similar maybe
two hotspots on the hot regions on the
DNA where maybe just because the
sequence is open in an open conformation
everything sticks a little bit and you
must remember of course RNA comes in
many many companies it's not just two
alleles here so of course you can see a
mixture you could actually really see a
mixture of the same location in
different mRNA copies being occupied by
different factors but of course that I
wouldn't really expect that that has the
same phenotypic impact than one that's
really covered always by the same factor
very specifically and so these are kind
of the things that we do now in terms of
the modeling to try to account for these
biases and do an integrated analysis and
get a bit better head way in which of
these many sites that we find are
functional and then to come back to the
question hopefully then for those
subsets for instance we can also figure
out some of the more subtle arrangements
thank you